eight full years after the series finale
of dexter aired and promptly became one
of the most frustrating show endings
ever for fans the serial killer focused
drama is making its grand return the
10-episode revival titled dexter new
blood was officially ordered in october
2020 with michael c hall set to reprice
this role as a serial killer to end all
serial killers since the announcement
more returns from exciting cast members
including jennifer carpenter who plays
dexter's sister deborah and john lithgow
who played season 4's trinity killer
have been revealed fans of the show
while enthusiastic about the return of
carpenter were also a bit confused about
what exactly her return would look like
after all deb dies in the show's series
finale it's a major reason that dexter
decides to fake his own death and start
her life as a lumberjack far away from
his hometown of miami florida really
there were only two viable options for
deb's place in the revival either she
would show up in flashbacks or she would
take the place of dexter's father harry
who often appeared in the original
series as a representation of dexter's
internal monologue surrounding his urge
to kill in a recent panel at showtime's
television critics association carpenter
finally revealed the role her character
would play in the revival not only is
she taking the place of harry who tried
to appeal to dexter's better angels with
his moral code of conduct she'll also be
the manifestation of dexter's darker
urges his dark passenger deadline
reports that a showtime tca panel
jennifer carpenter confirmed that her
character will be taking on the role of
dexter's dark passenger the internal
manifestation of dexter's long-held
desires to kill
i call that my dark passenger
you gave it a name
speaking about her return carpenter said
i love the concept of the dark passenger
and being invited into dexter's psyche
it was an opportunity not to be an angel
or devil on his shoulder but to jerk the
wheel to the left or right against his
will and to manipulate him to navigate
him to abuse him to save him i felt like
it was something entirely different than
some sort of ghost entity
michael c hall added on to carpenter's
sentiments noting that because of the
way deb's death affected dexter she was
the perfect evolution of the dark
passenger paul said she's an
internalized character for dexter that
represents just how far he's come or how
far he's fallen internally reeling and
without a compass in a sense as much as
he'd like to have one showrunner clyde
phillips added that deb is actually
quote more than a dark passenger he said
she represents a corner of dexter's mind
that we all have in our own heads that
says well wait a minute if you do this
then there are consequences
dexter's been away for nearly a decade
what kind of monster will he be
in case you need a refresher on the
history of dexter and the dark passenger
from the original dexter series
everything begins after a three-year-old
dexter sees his mother viciously
murdered with a chainsaw harry morgan
the biological father of deb finds
dexter at the crime scene and adopts him
as his own son tormented by his mother's
death dexter starts showing the
signature signs of psychopathy mainly
killing animals so harry makes the
decision to use this urge to kill for a
twisted form of justice arguably harry
is the entire reason dexter becomes a
serial killer albeit one who tries to be
relatively moral about it so although
his father dies years before the first
season of dexter harry lives on in
dexter's mind keeping a stun in line
with the set of moral rules they set up
long ago called the code of harry
he gave me a code
throughout dexter it's constantly in
question whether or not harry did the
right thing by guiding dexter down this
path it seems like deb will be following
in those ambiguous footsteps in her own
role as a dark passenger it appears that
the dark passenger is formed from
dexter's most dramatic experiences and
while it forces him to pause and
consider difficult decisions depending
on dexter's current state of mind it
might not guide him to make the right
choice if there even is one as dexter
new blood will also focus on the
relationship between dexter and his son
harrison played by jack alcott with whom
he'll be reunited 10 years after they
were separated in the original finale
the main thing fans have been wondering
about is if harrison has inherited his
father's killer tendencies and if so
will he have his own version of the dark
passenger we can't wait to see how deb's
version of the dark passenger plays out
in dexter new blood when it premieres on
november 7th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one